favorite clothing line of a movie what
is it could be several different movies
Stan that's a good question
favorite clothing line of a movie maybe
Fight Club you met me at a strange time
in my life I always loved because it's
so dry kind of I remember a lot of
clothing lines of the movie but they one
interesting thing about it well is that
in screenwriting class they taught us
that you can look in good scripts you
can look at the very first line in a
script and the very last line in the
script and if it's written well then you
can see the character change in those
two lines or the the whatever the movie
was communicating to you it's supposed
to be like one view of the world is the
first line and the change view of the
world is the last line I haven't
examined a lot of scripts as that is
actually the case but I love the idea
that ideally the protagonist talks
differently says something different and
most of the time probably the opposite
of what he said in the beginning in the
end if that character changed that we
talked about you know that day and
rebirth thing is fully delivered that
that might be the case is that the case
for you met me at a strange point in my
life I don't know the first line of
Fight Club is I would have to look that
up I don't know but that's the theory so
looking at some of your films was there
an ending line where you said no no
we've got a it's got to be delivered in
a different tone there has to be a
different look in the eye it's not why I
envisioned every single one because I
think because becomes the point where
the movie takes over and tells you what
it wants to be such a cliche line but
it's so true that that thing on the
screen suddenly is something different
from what you imagined that in my
experience the ending that I initially
shot never works I might as well for the
next project let's not shoot an ending
cut the film together and then see what
ending it wants to have but with 13 sins
at least I learned that that at least
shot two endings knowing that and then I
was like let's see which ending presents
itself and wants to be itself more and
that was interesting cuz I usually am
always for the darker ending they're not
the darker the darker the better because
it has that air of it's more intelligent
or some witch's nonsense why is it more
intelligent telogen if your protagonist
dies in the end than when he doesn't but
I always feel like I've delivered
Shakespeare there's death in the end
rather than happy Hollywood ending but
in 13th since we shot two endings one
dark one where the protagonist does die
and one lighter one where he doesn't and
for the first time when I played them
both I have the feeling I want the
lighter one because I have seen this
character go through all these trials
and tribulations before ninety minutes
for two hours he doesn't deserve to die
like he deserves I means too much to me
to sacrifice them at the end of the
movie you know and then we test screen
both movies and got the same feedback
that people say it's so dark please at
least give us an ending that is not even
darker than though it's not just the
ending line because you have to look in
his face or something another thing
that's important is the end music it
took us forever for the light more
lighthearted version for 13 cents which
is still pretty dark to find the right
end track because that is how you
release the audience back into the world
with that feeling right it's a
combination of the last line of the last
look of the last image this is the crane
shot that goes back or the nature
restore it or what or you go in it is
open in that order and then
unfortunately I wish you didn't have to
but you kind of have to show your hands
a little bit by choosing the end track
that you're choosing because it does
give away what you want the audience to
feel we talked about that earlier we you
know how vulnerable you are as a
filmmaker is the audience knows what you
are trying to make them feel at which
emotion you're trying to manipulate them
into nothing says that more overtly then
you're closing
music over the credits it took us
forever to try different different music
stuff and it was a different movie every
single time then man we found wonders
just in between where you where was not
clear what the movie wanted you to feel
hopefully which might be uncomfortable
for a lot of audience was like the one
you talked about where someone wants a
happy end and the kavika closed off and
they would probably hate that ending to
begin with and then with that music as
it leads that emotionally a little bit
ambiguous but I kind of loved that for
the enemy but that was the Bourne series
because the music from the first one I
can remember doesn't necessarily make me
feel like it's a total happy ending but
there's a promise in the music but it
doesn't mean that everything is rosy and
that's what I'm trying to say I don't
know you think it's a bit I would
remember the alcoholics course but I
think that's exactly what you wanted to
be if it's not a closed ending because
everything is rosy is not a very inch
it's not a very challenging now ending
and if you're trying to make a movie
where where people will gather in groups
outside of the theater to discuss and
the doubter they are screaming at each
other the better because you're
succeeding you you know kind of you
brought up emotions but let your own
opinion about it be as much on the
background as possible and let it be
ambiguous that to me feels very grown-up
because you're giving the audience
you're releasing them ideally with a
question and not with an answer that is
the addition at least what eleven works
or not I don't know but I think great
great movies do that Fight Club does a
lot of features movies do that last
country here for sure does that on a
great skiing with other questions about
humanity that you're being so I don't
know how the Bourne series handles that
but I could imagine with the characters
complex enough that you can't force them
into a clean cut this is a positive
ending kind of thing so that makes a
little sense to me
aside from your screening in Kosovo
which we know you you did not probably
stand outside and listen to some of
the group's because there are other
issues going on but from other maybe
more tame screenings have you sort of
lingered outside just to hear even the
intensity and the discussion even the
words being said but the the passion in
someone who avoids when they were
debating with a friend over something
none of my own with my own will be so
much because I'm mostly in the Q&A and
that discussion happens right there in
the audience which I love that sometimes
happens that one person asked the
question and then somewhere in the
audience just when I'm about to answer
answers that question but in with an
attitude and then that person is there
is something happening and the more of
that happens but better you know the
more involved people feel doesn't mean
they love the movie necessarily some
people might hate the movie would have a
very strong opinion about something and
then that triggered royalism but I've
seen it with other movies wings of
desire when I first watched wings of
desire that was the afternoon when when
then didn't benders wind winters
eloquent settings there was the
afternoon show that I arrived for the
evening's show and there were all these
people these little proves standing from
the theater
debating as if it was like college
course or something and I was like well
I wonder what movie I'm getting myself
into here you know about breaking the
waist I think the same thing where
people break the waist to me is one of
those movies that I can't I watch it
every single time it's screened
somewhere because every time I'm hoping
that this time she's going to make it
this time she's going to survive I know
it's a movie it's probably going to end
the same way it ended last time but that
character has me so much that for some
reason she's become real to me and I'm
you know following her wherever she
screening within hundred miles breaking
the web and after that movie I can never
talk but a lot of people can and there
are the most Christian Tyler hater or
lover or but everyone has a relationship
with the protagonist you know and that
is definitely one of the movies that
leads to discussions outside of the
movie theater
it's an interesting feeling when you
really wouldn't you just speechless and
you can't even make small talk yes
after a film I've been there many times
and you have to maybe use the bathroom
or you have to go get a drink of water
or something and yet the base human
being with me would take days oh wow I
want to go home as quickly as possible
and that's not just when something is
tragic I felt like that after the
revenant
like it's just being overwhelmed by
either the filmmaking quality or the
protagonists fate in the story or
something you know it's like it has to
be a pretty bad movie for me to want to
discuss it with someone right afterwards
you know a lot of bad movie but it is
someone that does not have its hooks in
me so much that I will think about it in
a week or two to come do you think
that's an introvert extrovert issue oh
because I wonder if because introverts
are so internal and that's not to say
extroverts don't feel things in our
internal at times but extroverts need to
vocalize but so much where is introverts
really just and
they just let it ruminate and we kind of
have to work it out in our own head I
think that it's always the realest thing
that that extroverts get energy from
contact with other people in nature
words sucks energy out of them right and
they gain energy from being internal
yeah ain't by themselves so that will
make sense to me that if I'm already so
exhausted emotionally by the movie I
have no more energy to give so I can't
interact with people that which would
then need require more energy because I
don't have that energy I just need to go
home and we can't gain that energy or
something I don't know that's
interesting
have you ever had trouble even driving
and sometimes it's like I think I need
to pull on the side street just said
you're gonna like it
after certain films until I can move no
okay but there was make that don't don't
drive emotionally impacted other let's
move it a go
you